barack obama gave a number of interviews
including to cbs's 60 minutes which we
will get to
but also uh to gail king and
it was very interesting to hear barack
obama's perspective on the last four
years
and on the election uh that joe biden
has defeated donald trump and the
implications and one of the messages
that barack obama focused on not just in
this interview
but in others as well is that this is
not normal and it's an important message
we've been talking about hyper
normalization for four years
let's take a listen to the former
president here i think we were in a
circumstance in this election
in which certain norms
certain institutional values that are
so extraordinarily important
had been breached that it was important
for me
as somebody who had served in that
office
to simply let people know this is not
normal so i've talked about this and i
talked about this when donald trump was
elected and we saw
things are going to be insane i started
saying i am going to try to prevent the
normalization of insanity
and it's something we've continued
talking about and we've had to fight and
it happens to all of us there is no way
to see daily scandal and embarrassment
and humiliation
day after day after day and not to some
degree
become desensitized to it to another
attack on the media
to another attack on democracy to
another attack on
the sort of fundamentals that this
country is based on and barack obama
nicely lays out
this is not normal none of this is
normal and barack obama
also lays out that he's very concerned
about the 72 million people that voted
for donald trump
whose world view is largely informed by
radical right-wing media
exactly as i've been talking about for
the last several months take a listen to
this
72 million people voted for donald trump
what does that say to you about the
state of this country
well what it says is that we are still
deeply divided the power
of that alternative
worldview that's presented in the media
that those voters consume
it carries a lot of weight are you
worried about that yes
it's very hard for our democracy to
function
if we are operating on just completely
different sets of facts but as clear as
we sit here today
we're not going to have a peaceful
transition i think about john mccain
calling george and laura bush welcoming
you and michelle obama to the white
house could not have been more gracious
i remember you inviting donald trump to
the white house
if you succeed then the country succeeds
i wish that you succeed because we want
the country to succeed
he does not seem to have taken a page
out of any of those playbooks
no so what is at stake here
well look joe biden will be the next
president of the united states kamala
harris will be the next vice president
there is no legal basis there's no
getting support from members of the
republican party who are not challenging
him
and that has been disappointing yeah
but it's been sort of par for the course
during these four years
they obviously didn't think there was
any fraud going on because they didn't
say anything about it for the first two
days
barack obama was also asked about his
demeanor on the campaign trail when he
was out there
for joe biden over the last few weeks
and barack obama pointed out that
he was not so much going in on trump he
was stating facts he was just repeating
things trump said verbatim
it wasn't personal actually you didn't
have a i've had it moment the truth is
everything i said
i was just stating facts you've got a
president right now he wants full credit
for an economy that he inherited he
wants zero blame
for the pandemic he ignored it was out
of character for you to speak up mr
president that way
i was not the person who had a
white house briefing room said how
is bleach the way to solve covit i
wasn't doing a routine i was repeating
words that i heard we talked about how
it is
really difficult to massively deprogram
millions of cultists and case in point
last week i took a very interesting call
from from a fellow youtuber who has a
small channel
who said david i was able to do it i
deprogrammed a trumpist
and i said great well so how did it
happen and the
the guy said well i had him on my
youtube channel
for three hours for a one-on-one
conversation
and that is a very difficult timeline
for the massive deprogramming of 72
million people now you can say
you don't have to deprogram all 72
million if you can deprogram
10 15 percent of them you're already
shifting the electoral balance
dramatically but the first step
to massive deprogramming has to be
massive denormalization it has to be
the masses must re-realize they must
again come to realize
that this is not normal that it's
whacked i don't really know how to do it
one thing
i thought about over the weekend was
would the realization that trump doesn't
care about them play a role in the
deprogramming and what i mean by that is
donald trump's supporters are
people that trump wouldn't be caught
dead with most of trump supporters are
people
trump has spent his entire life avoiding
by flying private and living where he
has lived
and so on and so forth and
you just have to look at this weekend
for a perfect example there was this
big protest in favor of trump in dc
people going crazy and we'll talk about
that a little bit later trump
literally drives by the protest waving
from inside
his armored vehicle on his way to spend
the weekend playing golf
he doesn't care about them and i'm just
thinking out loud here
if trump supporters came to really
understand that
trump doesn't give two you-know-whats
about them would that help
to deprogram them and i'm reminded of an
lbj quote
lyndon b johnson the former president
who said if you can convince the lowest
white man that he's better than the best
colored man
this was the vocabulary of the time he
won't notice you're picking his pocket
hell give him somebody to look down on
and he'll empty his pockets
for you that's who trump has targeted
and who primarily has to be deprogrammed
so bottom line
i'm glad barack obama is saying these
things
i'm disgusted and horrified that things
like this have to be said
that it has to be mentioned trump
continuing to claim he won
is a disaster for the for the united
states it's an embarrassment
um trump attacking the media trump
attacking these fundamental institutions
the fact that we have to mention hey
guys by the way this is bad this isn't
normal
that's the tragedy and a peaceful
transfer of power
of course is important joe biden won
that's not a controversial thing to say
or at least it shouldn't be
but 86 percent of trump voters don't
believe
that joe biden legitimately won i
imagine that as we get closer to
inauguration
that number will decline this episode is
sponsored by blue chew one of the things
i make a priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night even on a full stomach
since it's chewable
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discrete package
they're made in the usa and since
bluetooth prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's blue
chew.com promo code
pacman to try it totally free bluechu
is the better cheaper faster choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show